has America done it's going to be
interesting are we going to Costa Rica
boys they do jail him oh Chris Tropicana
Boulevard
[Music]
probably one of the biggest news stories
in the world that we didn't get to cover
because we were like in between JK's
um have you guys seen Trump's mug shot
yeah like he posed for it uh he was like
dude he made Hello money dude I saw
people with shirts no you got it oh my
God oh my God oh my God there's always a
critical advisors
dude you got it in time did you buy it
from I got it right away did you buy it
from his store or did you get it from
like no I made this
I actually did with the parents I made
it yeah
[__] no because I was like dude I could
do way cheaper than [__] 40 bucks
40 bucks the [__] that blew my mind is
he's sold it on his side dude for me I'm
like Trump 47 bucks right swap meet
mentality yeah dude he that guy moves
merch bro nobody moves no president has
moved amazing like Trump do we have like
stats of how much sales so he has
already raised more than 7.1 million
dollars there's since that just selling
the merch just well I think it's just
donations and merch right but we don't
it's not he's a good businessman is what
he does this guy yeah he capitalizes the
way I picture this dude is like he's
like the like the tacky Furniture Store
commercial rich guy yeah like he's like
you're like Main Street rich guy that
you that I think that's why you look at
him and you're like all right you're
hanging out with these billionaires but
your tactics reminds me of car sales
guys oh yeah he's tacky as hell it's
hilarious when he was selling steaks at
The Sharper Image it's one of the
funniest things I've ever seen like how
do you sell a steak you're selling Stace
yeah dude he was selling Trump sticks at
The Sharper Image oh my god do they even
have food exactly it's the weirdest move
ever ever
yeah but no he raised a shitload of
money right
um who's buying Stakes of the shirt
crazy yeah it's pretty intimidating it's
like it's one of those things too where
people are wondering is he gonna be
smiling is he gonna be like he went
angry in his face he went angry a little
bit he went [__] swamp from Mario and
then drops down yeah dude 100
um what do you guys think about all this
[__] what crazy this is in Georgia this
is the Georgia Fulton County Georgia
yeah and this is for uh messing with the
ballots allegedly that's yeah that's
what's being alleged that he uh scheme
to overturn the 2020 election they're
actually putting him and his team
um under Rico which is Met originally it
was men that's gonna be us to create uh
a way to take down the mafia because in
organized crime days like the top bosses
you weren't able to pin them on anything
yeah because all the dirt was being done
by the the guys down here the Minions
doing the killing and all the illegals
money's getting kicked upwards right
guys so
that's basically what the original law
was created to do and then so now they
use that same type of way to indict him
but basically what they're saying is he
was like the [__] head honcho of this
whole operation but then everyone says
like when you look into it
by the individual things that they're
claiming like nothing will stick as an
actual crime but you could collect all
of these things together and say it's a
conspiracy because I feel like at that
time before he got popped for this every
week it was like Trump got indicted
Trump got done and in different states
too right his whole number script going
on too and I didn't know what the [__]
was going on because I was going to read
it
it is it's pretty interesting they're
turning him into a crazy like pop
culture figure like Billy the Kid or
something yeah
because he's getting steam off this I
feel like yeah definitely he keeps going
up and then DeSantis keeps going down
that type of attention he he's better at
working with this than anything else
yeah yeah this is his favorite animal so
are people who are trying to get him
like indicted or like whatever are they
thinking that this whole
there's so many things like that where
people like show his photo and they're
like look at him he said never stranger
and he just surrendered it's like that's
a surrender to you yeah I know how the
justice system works it's just [__]
he just split in to take his phone he
went in to go fundraise dude yeah
honestly he's moving merged yeah with
that picture the way for him to flip
that into this and like seven million
dollars this much time people don't
understand how much they play into his
game yeah it's like if you don't want
him elected [__] stop [__] talking
this guy's pro wrestling dog he's so pro
wrestling and you and I used to never
understand what that meant and because I
was growing up I thought wrestling was
real and I still do but like when I see
when I see guys like this I'm like oh
dude this is exactly what he wants he
wants the crowd to be like [__] yeah
he's
Kurt Angle bro
he wins every time Kurt Angle bro God
damn it I don't want him to be WWE
Champion
I think no matter how you feel about it
I think the marketing genius and his
ability to just [__] like flip things
on his enemies I'm just like wow bro
he's probably gonna win again dog I I
you know it's crazy to think but yeah
he's gonna he might be our president
it's one of those things where it's like
look you know what Thomas Jefferson said
he said um you know the law should be so
easy for people to understand that they
can read
um what's happening like in the
newspaper while like running while
jogging right and and I think that
something like this when you take uh
like Joe's saying they're trying to do
this whole conspiracy thing which which
also includes like the inside of his
brain where it's like we know that he
knows he lost but he's trying to
overturn the shits you have to prove
that you know that does anybody in this
room thinks that he thinks that he
thinks he lost the election like I don't
you know what I mean so it's one of
those things where you if you're going
to go after the bit your biggest
political opponent this is a Democrat by
the way in Fulton County who is who is
um charging him you're going after the
the opposite party's major leader you
better have something good like the guy
murdered somebody or something because
otherwise everyone who doesn't
understand your case has no faith in the
system right they think it's you're
you're doing something it's an attack
well it's because the hypocrisy behind
it right so if the indictment is because
he questioned the legitimacy of the um
you know the voting which you can do you
can question the legitimacy clear
there's clear video of Hillary Clinton
questioning the legitimacy of Trump's
win it's like so how can you say the
same things and indict him for the same
things that they were they were doing
exactly that's that's what people a lot
of people have problems with the
hypocrisy angle right but then there's
also the whole thing where
um it are we going to to really stand up
and talk about what a great democracy we
are and all this [__] when you're you're
indicting the the opposing parties
biggest player he's 60 points out of the
next guy 60 points 60 points he's up 60
percent
to DeSantis it's a troubling thing to
think that you can like if if this was
happening in any other country the state
department would be issuing a
declaration saying like yeah this is
[__] up don't indict your political
opponents right if if North Korea was
doing this like it'd be the same [__] so
it just makes people feel uneasy and I
think that also a guy who just got 75
million votes 76 million votes you're
basically saying that all those people
who voted for him like they're they're
not allowed to vote for him again that's
like saying half of America is like we
don't care we don't care you're not
allowed to we're going to put them we're
gonna lock him up and you're not going
to be able to vote for him even if you
want to yeah that's kind of a wild thing
think about when it comes to to the way
we were raised in America has it
happened at any point in history
not like this man Phil opponent got
indicted and they just got out of the
running like by force not that I'm aware
I mean they were going to do it to Nixon
they were going to do it to Nixon I was
during his campaign and he stepped down
yeah
but oh did you see by the way that all
like the dude they're starting to
sentence like all of the capital right
dudes and they're getting like massive
sentences yeah huge sentences 30 years
for them
wow but they don't know who the brought
the Coke in the white house
it's on every single person that was
there they're issuing money to the
protesters too on the other way around
like people that have been protesters
they'll get like 35 million for being
like locked up in jail overnight or
whatever wow do I see that for real 35
million oh the man should have protested
some more get some money yeah dude I
actually got locked up
that's the other way 35.
tax money there's a level of like I
guess like Integrity we need to keep in
the system or else once you opened up
the gates of corruption openly because
every country's corrupt but when you
openly do it right then I think you kind
of break that
that rule of like Hey we're supposed to
be playing by the same game absolutely
and then but then the I think the issue
here specifically is now we're going
into territory that we might not be able
to come back from yeah and even if I
disagree with my opponents right and I
don't like what what's being done or
whatever I think everybody needs to go
through due process or else once we lose
that we become a third world country
yeah well there's also an argument being
made that didn't Trump have due process
because the the House and Senate had a
impeachment proceeding and then he
actually made it through there so
basically it's like double double not
Double Jeopardy feels like it for some
people right it's like he had a trial in
the in the in the House and Senate and
they they acquitted him so like again is
this why did you wait till the
presidential election to charge him this
happened years ago because the
government's kind of lazy and they work
slow yeah that's why uh and also the
other thing about it too that kind of
that kind of scares me is like what what
you guys are saying about the precedent
for this like what who if you're gonna
do this can't they lock up Bernie can't
they lock up you know yeah J RFK Jr like
like all any of your political opponents
like you could you could really
weaponize the government against them
would be that that's the first thing you
need to find now when you're running
against somebody right he's like what
can I get them for at least that becomes
part of the Playbook now as soon as
Trump got elected what'd they say Russia
elected him it wasn't a fair election
Russia and then they investigated him
with the special prosecutor Robert
Mueller special counsel and then they
found out there was nothing there and
then and then James Comey who was the
FBI director during all this who's
allowing this investigation to proceed
he said that the steel dossier was in
the main not even true and he knew it
the whole time but then he's out there
on TV acting like it's a big thing it's
a big huge thing but then when he's
testifying under oath behind enclosed
doors send a testimony he's like in the
Mania we knew it wasn't true you know
what sucks the most is that like
everything you're explaining right now
it's all like
makes sense but yet someone's watching
you right now and summing you up and
just going Steve's a [__] Trumper
absolutely absolutely they don't see the
irony dude this is like the Bob Marley
mug shot like all the sad part is that
you're not no one's seeing the details
about how dirty this is because they're
[__] games
[__] is normal dude yeah none of this is
like correct this makes you worried this
is what I'm wishing people will start
seeing is like stop being such a dick
rider for one political party for real
please look at it as there's
establishment [__] bourgeoisie right
there's a group of people out there that
are so [__] Rich they play by these
games they don't give a [__] about us
but they pretend that they do then
there's a different Group which is
called like it anti-establishment
they're not a part of this club and
they're trying to come in on the right
and on the left Democrats and
Republicans they both existence right
and they're trying to make changes
they're trying to break up this
oligopoly
it's like this group that you have here
uh they work together the right and the
left it's not a conspiracy they're
called neoconservatives yeah they're
neoliberals they're Pro corporations
the [__] that they say might be
different when it comes to social issues
on abortion or whatever but if you look
at how they vote on policy it's all in
unison the [__] that they speak they'll
never go against the war they'll never
go against Ukraine they'll never like
you'll start to see that the things that
they say it's rehearsed it's told to
them what to say and it doesn't [__]
matter if they're right-wing or left
wing and that's where I think people
don't [__] understand they go oh if
you're not a Democrat you're not a
minority because you're a white lover
and then it's like are you [__]
stupid you think the people on the left
actually care about you they don't
that's just right they prove it they
prove it with their actions all the time
yeah everyone on the right and left
prove it constantly by doing nothing for
anybody yeah they don't care about the
working class hell no they don't give a
[__] America baby America America bumps
me out are we done is this it are we
done so is it are we moving we'll see
what happens is America done it's gonna
be interesting are we going to Costa
Rica boys they do jail him oh Chris
Tropicana Boulevard
that's not in South America